I just feel empowered I feel like I'm on
the highest horse anyone could ever sit
on I feel like I'm the only one here
just me and my money it's my job to
bring the sides back down to earth and
run him through the family's budget but
now it's the moment where things are
gonna get a bit serious because I think
you must know that that's so much money
there must be a lot of things that your
family has to buy it has to pay for
right
so I'm gonna show you what some of them
are so I run Versailles through the
day-to-day costs that he'll be
responsible for these include food
clothing and entertainment now this is
if you like sort of like your little
playground
you can choose however you want to use
it I'm going to give you some time to
have a think about this and to come up
with your own plan yes
all right it's not good luck and I'll be
nearby just call out if you need some
help all right Cheers figuring out the
family's budget can be a challenge
probably should be fine but when your
dad's a banker the pressures really on I
just want to see the figures and see
what these allocations are what he's
going to spend on and what he's not
going to spend on that's what I love to
see 35 this will let us know whether he
values what we value and whether he
values the idea that I would like a
massage or not whether he thinks I'm
being a spendthrift there or not hey 100
treasonable I just gotta be as nice as I
can to us in sugar and mops you know I
get that little bit of extra money
question really what at the mercy of us
and hoping that he does the best for the
family